- More importantly, when
I come back in September,
we're gonna come with
some real fire on YouTube,
so YouTube, get ready.
Me and the team are gonna spend this time
to really come back with the 4.0 version
of what we're doing here.
♫ Me and GaryVee up in the office
♫ Do-rag flappin'
walkin' through corporate
♫ Talks about ownership and leverage
♫ 1800 checks and shy out of average
(mellow hip hop music)
- It's very simple at its most binary.
If you actually realize
that you're a media company,
and then you do whatever you do,
well then everything else flows.
To me, it's about being able to stay alive
to make your media pure
so that you can capitalize on the back end
because you have a much bigger audience.
The people that are selling programs
on Instagram and YouTube,
they're not on the cover of Forbes.
They're not on CNN.
These things matter, brand.
Brand is the single reason that
I'll be the guy of this era,
and it will be the thing
that I push you towards
this entire time.
All the things I preach, patience.
It takes time to build a brand,
but it's the brand part that will matter.
And it's understanding the following,
you will never trick the market.
- Let me ask you this.
How many people in the course of your day,
as you're providing content,
will ultimately bring
that to the web for you?
- My team now?
- Yeah.
- 15.
15?
- But here's the good news.
24 months ago, one.
One thing that we've
all stepped into shit in
is every nine year old can do it all.
- [Man In Plaid] Dude. (laughs)
- There's literally two
24 year olds right now
who don't get to do what they wanna do.
These kids believe, and especially,
it's one thing about what
Shoots does and what I do,
that's different.
That's traditional.
But the actual creation,
distribution, and editing?
Nine out of 10 times the 23 year old's
better than 34 year old
because they're more native and have,
Iris, how long have you been
doin' your thing with video?
- [Iris] I started my YouTube in college,
second year of college, and
I just graduated last year.
- Right, they come with four--
Right?
- Whatever, look, I'm sure--
- You know what I mean?
There's people who've been
doing it since they were nine.
I view editing and production
and engineering and creation
far more like the NBA where
if you're good enough at 18,
you're just good enough.
It's a talent.
I prefer you hire it as your overhead
because my intuition is
you'll be more successful.
- Is there a place on the internet--
- [Gary] To find these people?
- No, where a person can
publish the equivalent
of an episodic reality show not
through an existing Netflix?
So say I had an idea for a program.
- I do that.
I do that.
- [Man In Plaid] 30-minute shows.
- Have you ever seen DailyVee?
- [Man In Plaid] Yes.
- That's what I do.
That's what this is right now.
- [Man In Plaid] Right.
- It's called Facebook and YouTube.
- [Man In Khaki Pants] You're on it.
(laughter)
- [Gary] You're on it.
You're really on it.
Listen, I'm only on a different level
because I did exactly what you just said.
Instead of begging Netflix
and Hulu and Amazon and ABC,
I just went to the consumer at scale.
It's called Facebook and YouTube, man.
Apple came to me.
To do it the right way, it's all marathon.
To do it the wrong way, it's sprint,
and that's why, you know.
If you can leave here with knowing
that you're a media company,
and your behavior should map towards it
and you separate and don't have pregnant
the sales and branding, and you
can create that environment,
then you've got something.
Shoot for the moon because if
you land at the clouds, cool.
If you shoot for the clouds,
you're going to be at the top of a tree.
(buoyant music)
- Thanks, man.
- See you guys later, enjoy.
The themes of the day of
the last week really impacts
all of us, actually
that's why we're all here.
We have to get out of the business
of having brains doing brawn.
Listen, I'm going to
say something right now.
I'm going away for three weeks.
I've been on fire for the last two months.
You got a lot to do, but please can we,
like Tyler, I don't give
a fuck, like watch shit.
- Well that's why, it's gonna be good.
So our next three weeks is
basically what we're doing,
this DailyVee season thing.
So next week is season one recap,
which is like one through 91,
which Ellie already went
all the way through.
So there's not going to
be as much gold there,
but we're going to replay it out.
She's halfway through season two,
and all of season three has
never even been re-looked at.
And so my biggest
difficulty this whole time,
it's always been the biggest
problem for like two years,
but I don't know what I don't
know and I'm just keep going
versus having these people
have access to this footage.
- The other thing is we
could make so much gold.
Do you know how cool it
would be for me just for fun,
I want to make some
ha-ha throw away content,
like 7 1/2 hours of me taking selfies.
I like hacking culture.
Let's put up a 7 1/2-hour video,
7 1/2 hours with every song
we've ever used on DailyVee,
of me just taking selfies.
And I don't care if anybody watches that.
Nobody wants to watch that.
I just want it to exist.
Things like that where it's
more like just branding, ha-ha
like hacking.
Here's why what I just said was super good
and what has to be our culture.
Okay, so there's that.
Eric hates it.
I'm whatever.
But here's what's funny.
Me even thinking Eric hates
it makes me then react,
so then I go hmm okay, how
do I make this more valuable?
Aha!
I'm going to get HarperCollins
to release the audio
of The Thank You Economy for
free, and I'm going to put it
on the back of 7 1/2 hours
of fucking me taking selfies.
And now I'm like, hey gang.
The Thank You Economy audio.
Free, here it is, link.
Oh by the way, I put seven
hours of me taking selfies
with you guys on it.
Thank you, you know.
Got it?
Good idea.
There it is.
That's how I brainstorm everyone.
I didn't take vacations when
you and I knew each other.
There's a very funny --
- Why don't you take the first one?
- There's very funny things that happen
when I go on vacation.
- [Team Member] Yeah, he
talks to us about work.
(laughter)
- I will literally talk to you more--
- That's great.
- On the first day.
This week's my parents,
but at home you will hear from me like 80,
you see, I talk to you on the weekends.
It's about to get real serious up in here.
- [Team Member] Okay, we're gonna go.
- Let's go.
(mellow music)
- In a different world,
I would probably be
an all-time debate champion.
- Oh yeah.
- In a different world, you know?
- You just wait to hear their
M.O., and then counter with--
- I'm like karate.
I let their force make
them walk into them.
Heading down to Long Island City.
YouTube, this is gonna be your first look.
We built a huge studio in Long Island City
for all the production
capabilities we want, for video
and audio where we'll do
our original podcast series
that we're going to
continue to make for clients
and ourselves, where we're doing all sorts
of Facebook commercials for our clients.
I'm gonna try to hack it.
Obviously a lot of times
when I'm going to airports,
it's better for me to be there.
So rare footage of me in the subway.
Subway life.
Iris, it's crowdy.
(mellow music)
- How's it going?
- Good.
- You learning?
- Lots of, lots, lots, lots.
- What are the most unusual things?
How is it different with me?
- Five-minute meetings.
Back-to-back.
- It's unusual.
- Yes, and the energy.
- Hey!
- What's up man?
- How's it going, brother?
- Good, brother, how are you?
- Good.
- You know what I love it?
Because I feel like--
- I wanna be just like you.
- Oh my God.
And I like, the energy that you,
the vibe, good positive everything.
- Honey over vinegar.
- Yes.
(laughter)
(hip hop music)
♫ They don't wanna see you win
♫ Put you down and keep you in
- How's everything?
- I'm excited.
Hey, hey.
♫ Flex and say say I did it
♫ Yeah, don't wanna see you win
♫ Put you down and keep you in
♫ I been workin' for a minute girl
♫ So I can flex and say I did it
♫ They don't wanna see you win
♫ Met her on the west side
- What's up?
- Life is good, boys.
- How you doing?
- How are you guys?
- Doing well.
I mean, one big question I
have, and it's almost like
don't want to put you on the spot, but--
- I'm comfortable on the spot.
- (laughs) VaynerSports isn't
about collecting contracts.
Okay, it's just not.
It's about completely full service
and honestly being true to it.
- Yes.
- To do that, you almost need to blow up
the client-to-staff ratio that's currently
in place in the agency space.
So what's your plan to growth hack that?
How are you going to get
around the status quo?
- By not caring about
how much money we make.
- So it's that extra long term.
That's like what we were
talking about with Tyler.
Right now guys will leave to
go because they see the chains.
They see the cars.
But if they're really
thinking what's best for me.
- You guys know this with consuming
whatever level of content
you consumed with me.
I'm giving people the blueprint.
I just don't think they have
the skills to execute it.
I'm showing people what to do,
how to think about it, what works.
People aren't built for it.
Alpha male, 22 years old,
Hey, bro.
Eat shit for a decade.
And don't enjoy all the alpha bro things
that come along with being
an alpha male from 22 to 32.
How many dudes signing up? (clicks tongue)
- Zero.
- I don't think people understand
what we're about to do in that world.
You get to see it firsthand.
You'll be just like the people
that were at Vayner seven years ago.
When you're in a big nice
fancy VaynerSports office,
you'll be like, "No, no,
we started in VaynerMedia.
"People didn't even know.
"We sat by Iris."
You know what I mean?
- There were six of us in
a row bumping shoulders
with Danny.
- Yep.
And now they have Payton Manning
and Tom Brady and Michael Jordan.
Right?
That's what's gonna happen.
It's a foregone conclusion.
As long as A.J. Knight's still healthy
it's just what's going to happen.
It's because of the balance
between the talent and the patience.
If you're actually great
and you're actually patient,
you become fundamentally unbeatable.
Did you see that moment,
I'm sure you guys watched
USC Talk right?
The best moment of that
whole talk is when I'm like
this is the best, most
you can ever have it.
Gratitude, it's just gratitude.
One life, one at bat, one time.
I just don't want to see
that regret in my eyes
that I see in so many,
and that's why it's so fun
for me to come and talk to you now.
Because it's like, straight
up, for 90% of you,
this is the greatest era
of your life right now.
That's just the truth.
You can be mad at me.
You can be sad at me.
You can think I'm stupid.
I'm telling you straight
to your fucking faces,
for 80 to 90% of you this is it.
This is the fucking pinnacle,
so you better squeeze the
fuck out of this thing.
Because if you're smart and
you do, then it won't be.
That was such a fuck you moment.
- The guy to your left--
- Laughed.
- [Man] They're like,
"You're right." (laughs)
- Whether they think I'm right
or they thought, "Fuck you,"
I'm still gonna be right.
- Makes sense.
- But it's all about the kid.
It's all about the CEO.
It's all about the quarterback.
It's about saying yes for everybody
and accepting no from everybody.
Yeah that's a good spot.
I just think everybody's gonna say yes
when I pitch them something.
But I'm super cool when 90% say no.
And I make my bread on
the 10 that say yes.
And then I stick it to
the people that said no.
I'll never be too fancy.
I just can't.
It's not in me.
I can't sell out.
It's just not in me.
- I guess it goes back to just the balance
of the jockey versus the horse
and so you're gonna go
with the jockey every time.
- One thing I will tell you
is if in three years from now
the number one rated quarterback
is begging me to take him,
and he's a douchebag,
we're not taking him.
So there's that.
On the flip side, if I
fall in love with a punter
in nine years, we'll go.
So it's, got it?
- Yeah.
- It's more about the human.
- What type of agent are
you going to be looking for
at VaynerSports say in eight years?
- I don't know, I don't know.
I don't know enough yet.
I'm still tasting.
I'll be able to really answer
that in two or three years,
just not yet.
- What type of qualities do you think
that ace needs to have?
- They need to look like
they could be an AJ.
They need to be a fuckin
stone cold assassin
but a good human being.
Like just 'cause she can close everybody
doesn't mean she can be
a douchebag to everybody.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Just gotta be straight
up fuckin the best winner.
- How much of that do you think's natural?
- A lot.
A lot.
- I guess not the good
person part but the--
- Charisma's super hard to create.
To be binarily an
assassin is teachable-ish.
I see the confidence in
the people around me grow,
but not to become me.
So I think of it like
basketball, actually football,
but let's use basketball
because it's a little bit different.
I think all four of us could
be better basketball players.
I don't think we can be LeBron.
I think if I play
basketball five hours a day
starting tomorrow at
41 years old every day
that in two years I can really play.
I think my left will fully develop.
I think I'll be really good.
And.
A lot.
I think the key for you
guys, all three of you,
at this young of an age is to figure out
what were the things that you were given
and make them better.
So if you're kind, become the
most kind person of all time.
Betting on strikes,
obsessed with that thesis.
Okay cool, YouTube.
Go get more charismatic like me.
You're not gonna do it.
But if you are then fuckin'
triple down on that,
but don't be full of shit
and use your charisma
as a negative.
(alternative rock music)
- Thank you so much.
- Take care.
Talk to you soon.
- Good talking to you.
- [Jake] Good talking to you as well, man.
- Hey, I'm Brian.
- Such a pleasure.
- The pleasure's mine.
(alternative rock music)
- I mean it because I think
I'm an all-time unique person.
I genuinely believe that.
- I believe that about you.
- And honestly I think I used to think it
for different reasons than I do now.
Now I really fucking
believe it. (laughing)
I think I before
intuitively thought maybe.
Now it's fuckin' obvious.
- Alright so Drew, the person who produced
a bunch of really fuckin' dope music
that I'm sure you would vibe out.
He loves smooth shit.
So his production style you'd love.
He's with all these West Coast artists
that we've messed with,
but now he has my favorite
hip hop clothing brand,
and he's just murdering it.
- [Drew] Super hip.
- It's right here, 40s and Shorties and...
Linking an influencer with him,
I feel like that would almost
make the influencer cooler.
(laughter)
- You know what I mean?
- Of course.
So when things are happening he's on top.
- He's hacking.
- And they move very fast.
- I get it.
Tell me about you.
Where'd you grow up?
- I'm originally from the Bay
area, and then I moved to LA
when I was like 21.
And then from there
I kind of just started everything
that I wanted to do.
- [Gary] What did the
21-year-old you think?
- When I moved to LA?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- Man, that's a lot of competition.
(laughter)
- It's gonna be a rough road.
That's the first thing
that popped in my head,
but I knew I wanted it so I just had to--
- [Gary] How old are you now?
- I'm 31.
- [Gary] You look good man.
- Thank you.
- [Gary] Got good DNA.
(laughter)
- He's just in the right mix.
- [Gary] I understand.
- I guess when you're
talking about influencers,
obviously you're with
a lot of influencers.
What are you trying to do?
- The end goal of it is just to have
more of just like a
longevity thing and have--
- [Gary] Longevity's going
to come at the variable
of how good you are at continuing
to do what you're doing.
Everybody starts off looking like you,
and then they sell out.
And then the streets don't fuck with them.
You know that.
- 100%.
- I don't have to explain it.
So the good news is, I don't
think influencers are the
vulnerability of, I know.
You know, everything
I've heard, I know you,
I'm just repeating shit you know.
It's just attention.
The key is it's my story.
The reason I'm never scared
is I'm not gonna sell out.
I'm never gonna think
I'm better than anybody.
Thus in the business
world, that's the sell out.
Let's get to know each other.
- Yeah.
- Real pleasure.
- Appreciate it.
- Yeah, keep doing your thing man.
- I will.
- Yeah, cool.
So here's what I would say.
How old are you?
- 22.
- You should 100% go
in the family business.
- Yeah?
- Let me tell you why.
- Why?
- You'll never regret it.
- Okay.
- You don't know how long
your mom and everybody else
is going to be on earth.
You will never regret going
into the family business.
You may completely waste
three years of your life.
It's just not that much time.
- Okay, it was nice to meet you.
Thank you, Gary.
- Okay, guys.
Before I go back into the city,
out here in Long Island
City, which has been amazing,
before I go back into the city,
this is a little bit of my sign off.
As you might have saw in
the article that I wrote,
let's put the URL here.
Let's create a little mini URL.
Let's link it in the
episode here on YouTube.
I'm going off the grid with family now
for the rest of August
right up until Labor Day.
I'm gonna attack it from the
August strategy that I have.
This has been an incredible
journey with you guys so far,
and this is the biggest break I'm taking
since I've been kind of all into my vlog.
I just want to thank you for that.
And more importantly when
I come back in September,
we're gonna come with
some real fire on YouTube,
so YouTube get ready.
Me and the team are gonna spend this time
to really come back with the 4.0 version
of what we're doing here.
(happy music)